as the new protagonist kasuga ichiban
steps into the spotlight for yakuza like
a dragon developer rgg studio proves it
can still capture its signature blend of
gripping melodrama and absurdist humor
while creating something genuinely fresh
for the long-running franchise
it's not just in the slick transition
from action brawler to turn-based combat
it's that the party dynamic in like a
dragon enables a new kind of story that
the series hasn't explored before
one that focuses on the power of
embracing friendship and fighting
together
every step of the way
leica dragon starts anew providing an
entry point for those who have never
played a yakuza game before but it
wouldn't be a proper series entry
without the core tenants that define
yakuza
things like captivating exposition heavy
cutscenes exciting over-the-top
fights and a wealth of side activities
that flood the streets of a life-like
japanese city
in true yakuza fashion the tangled web
of alliances betrayals
secrets and shifts in power across
different organizations serve as the
foundation for much of its
character-driven story
and it's as sweet as ever here much of
what propels like a dragon is the
connection that ichiban shares with his
tojo clan boss
and father figure masumi arakawa things
change over time though
and that good-natured kid who grew up
loving dragon quest and doing harmless
errands for the gang now has a lot to
learn about the criminal underworld
ichiban is loud goofy naive but always
well-meaning
others are there to help him learn and
grow and he stays dedicated to the
people around him
his companions whose circumstances bring
them together help
uncover the mystery behind his exile to
ijinsho yokohama where most of the game
takes place
adachi is the ex-detective whose goal is
tied to yours
nanba is the homeless man who saved your
life with more to him than he lets on
and psycho is the barmaid who gives back
the unconditional support she gets from
the crew
the familiar theme of deep emotional
bonds is what leica dragon uses to bring
something new to the series strong
established style of storytelling you
have a cast that gets into trouble and
fights
drinks and celebrates together and they
carry each other to the end much of the
yakuza series thus far was about the
struggles of cosmo kiryu a man who has a
heart of gold yet always kept everyone
at arm's length like a dragon however
explores the power of letting people in
and it embraces the uplifting social
dynamic its characters create okay
okay my ass are you dragging us into
another mess
you're finally starting to understand me
nurse namba
ah that's a bad sign you
in adachi-san about going up against a
guy even the police are scared of
my detective instincts are telling me
hell yeah let's do it
in yokohama you'll cross with the
japanese serious clan the korean gomijul
and the chinese lomang and the unnerving
tension between them and other outside
organizations
enriches the narrative it's an
ever-evolving game of 4d chess that
makes you eager to see what happens
chapter after chapter like a dragon gets
political too
and it takes narrative opportunities to
express clear opposition to
anti-immigration
anti-sex work and anti-poor politics in
key story beats
and these themes also become part of
what drives ichiban and company
you ever consider why a woman might do
this job because they have needs
some are caring for their parents some
have little kids
this is a way for them to support their
families now i'm a sucker for yakuza's
stories however i'm willing to admit
that like a dragon does try to pull
one too many easy plot twists and
perhaps bites off more than it can chew
at the tail end
they're not bad story beats per se but
they can feel overbearing when there's
already enough enticing narrative
established
regardless yakuza has built a reputation
on captivating drama and strong
characterizations and it's those
expectations that its games will be
judged by with that criteria in mind
like a dragon hardly ever misses
hey how's it going
well namba-san you tried to play nice
but you know what these guys when
fighting ichiban's imagination runs wild
in his mind he sees himself and his
friends as the heroes of the day
just like in dragon quest in battle
enemies transform into possessed beings
silly delinquents or just bad dudes with
glowing red eyes
and your own party members transform
into their equipped jobs with sometimes
ridiculous costume changes
like a dragon asks you to suspend your
disbelief more so than previous yakuza
games
to accommodate ichiban's childlike but
invigorating imagination
and you know what i'm here for it the
turn-based combat system has you
managing your party's various
capabilities and strategizing to
dispatch
enemies in smart ways when you barrel
down consecutive fights in dungeon-like
scenarios
combat maintains a steady enjoyable flow
whereas the bigger set-piece boss fights
test your command of the system
it comes together remarkably well for
yakuz's own rpg
debut combat is also an opportunity for
the game to crank up yakuza's tradition
of ridiculous over-the-top moves and the
intricacies of combat are driven by the
job system which is essentially a set of
swappable character classes that play
differently with their own goofy unique
abilities
[Music]
like a dragon isn't without its faults
however the last few chapters of the
game began to rely on long drawn out
fights
i still had to stay sharp but some later
bosses boiled down to a war of attrition
although i love that the game can be
really challenging a little grinding was
required to even survive against some
bosses
thankfully there is at least an avenue
for that you should also be aware that
there is a point in the story where
you're required to have lots of money
which can also break the pace if you
don't
the new location of ijinsho offers its
own distinct
vibe compared to kamurocho it feels like
taking a deep breath of fresh air when
you walk through the open spaces of
hamakita park through isuzusaki road's
shopping areas and through the streets
of chinatown
even the alleyways and homeless camps of
the lower class areas breathe life into
ijincho in equal measure
and the city is bustling with things to
do outside of the main story as is
yakuza tradition
my personal favorite of karaoke is back
the rhythm minigame presents another
avenue for characters to express
themselves and especially charming
fashion
ichiban confections the business
management simulator is the very
important money-making mini-game too
you help a family grow their business
from a hole-in-the-wall pastry shop to
becoming c-suite executives
it's silly as hell but quite involved as
you need to manage employees make
investment decisions
and play a separate and hilarious
mini-game of frantically arguing with
shareholders there's also dragon cart
which is an entire kart racing minigame
with its own ridiculous side story and
tournament style challenges
the last one i'll mention is the quiz
mini game which exists under the guise
of an adult school where ichiban learns
about history and culture
these activities are lively and
rewarding in their own small ways
[Music]
even after spending 40 hours with yakuza
like a dragon to complete its main story
and experience a decent chunk of
optional content there's still more to
see and do with sub-stories and optional
quests
now as the game executes on a
melodramatic multifaceted conclusion
typical of yakuza you're encouraged to
reflect on the hardships and tragedies
ichiban had to endure
you can see the journey the struggles
the challenges the growth and the
friendships worn plainly on his face
yakuza has a penchant for exaggeration
this game really goes for it and it
works
ichiban is an expressive character
sometimes to the point of parody but
it's endearing and often inspiring he's
also what his friends have made him
through their own personalities and
their sense of justice
a hero ichiban you're right
i am yeah so i see you do it
become a hero just like you wanted at so
many moments i stood up screaming at my
tv from absolute hype
seeing how ichiban develops and how like
a dragon ties back into the broader
yakuza
lore ichiban stands tall among the
legends that the yakuza games have
created and it can't help but feel a
reinvigorated passion for the franchise
for rgg studio's first crack at an rpg
it's a damn fine result
it delivers what i love most about
yakuza and introduces new ideas that
largely pay off
ichiban isn't doing it alone either he
has friends and mentors who've helped
him fight
and overcome personal tragedies and
that's what's most important for a game
so focused on its characters
yakuza like a dragon is a passing of the
torch and a fantastic entry and a
beloved franchise that proves that it's
in good hands with kasuga ichiban
today finally my blade will have its
do koi man
have your way with her